previously on TV since episode contains
no cold-open no turn on red signs I'll
turn on red when I damn well want to
Johnny long to think that I saw it on
Mulberry Street for a town that is
supposedly welcoming you there is a lot
of our nonsense on this sign so I guess
if you embrace their people in
traditions you will be met with open
arms for at least ones that are slightly
more John why is the businessman
levitating for this casual seated
observer ah sudden Homer Simpson on NBC
show do you really have to do that right
now
yes I do I'm not necessarily defending
Dwight but Jim was clearly having issues
hearing mr. Decker before Dwight started
his shredder thong so what I was saying
hello if you thought hearing a dial tone
was incorrect when someone hangs up on
you imagine having the gonads to play a
dial tone and when the hanging up is
actually happening on your end the phone
is literally hung up where is that noise
even supposed to be coming from why is
Dwight shredding this credit card when
it appears to be the exact same credit
card he shredded mere seconds ago in the
interim did it miraculously get put back
together how did the continuity
department miss something so obvious and
that one call ends up being 25% of my
commission for the whole year so you
know I buy any bottle of champagne given
these circumstances it may be more
appropriate to buy a dozen eggs so that
you can keep them in one basket
voluntary yeah Freeza Freeza look Pam if
you're wasting time at work on a Windows
machine and you're not playing
minesweeper we cannot be friends also
Pam clearly answers by saying yeah free
sell but the subtitles say yeah fraid
sup proving my point again that even the
subtitle Hoos think she should be
ashamed of her preferred choice of
lollygaggin Sampson I know I saw that
something money you know Jim would be
excellent at TV since I like it when the
cards go Jim and Pam are the best I mean
if you have to throw some will they
won't they into your sitcom this right
here is how you do it
we believe that 99% of the problems in
the workplace arise simply out of
ignorance the other 1% is leprechauns
leprechauns kevin is a great guy he's a
great accountant he is not much of an
entertainer
that's Kevin it's black people are
actually more racist because they hate
the other type of black people I know
everyone's familiar with Michael's
racist incident but Kevin is able to
rehash this bit pretty much verbatim I
forget stand-up jokes even the ones I
like minutes after I hear and laugh at
them every time people have a good time
no no no no no no no I don't care that
this was all the way back in 2005 I
don't care that Dunder Mifflin is a
dysfunctional company I don't care these
retelling a joke from a Chris Rock show
there's no goddamn way I'm letting my
brain justify the fact that a branch
manager just said to in front of a black
corporate employee on camera and didn't
get immediately fired or at least
shortly thereafter fire away in the
comments [ __ ] but I'm sticking with
my series of notes also also it should
be pointed out that this show is super
uncomfortable to watch it is funny at
times and maybe that's the point but I'm
still giving it a sin for making my skin
crawl
what is a hero to you a hero kills
people people that we should harm the
white is clearly a DC EU fan the only
reason why I make copies for everyone
was so that you wouldn't be embarrassed
if this were true couldn't you have just
met with Michael on one from the start
and no one would be wiser in this way I
can truly be a hero
signed Daffy Duck taking Looney Tunes in
vain also considering how different the
name Daffy Duck is from Michael Scott
and that diversity dude was sitting
right there watching him sign this with
this moment being his sole stated goal
how did he not notice that he signed the
wrong name immediately Jim chewing on
his pen is probably a sin enough but
he's obviously out of control because he
must have already devoured the pencil he
was chewing on just ten seconds ago how
did he film this without anyone else in
the office knowing even if it was during
lunch time every office has one or two
disgusting non health conscious people
that eat at their desk and yes Diane I'm
talking about you and your five day old
tuna salad Jim
hello what the hell just happened with
Jim he answered the phone on the second
ring but the caller had already hung up
and in the next scene he's completely
gone from his desk if we operated into a
horror movie all of a sudden there's
this great Chris Rock bit I'm not gonna
do it but it's what changed in the last
few hours since Michael was so oblivious
that he did the Chris Rock bit that got
him in trouble in the first place
why has he suddenly learned his lesson
when the whole point of the episode
seems to be that he is learning nothing
at the beginning of this game of that's
racist
Michael had them draw cards randomly so
why does Meredith's car and have her
name written on the back of it
we watched a fashio really yeah I think
she really likes to stop great she's kid
huh yeah she's engaged oh no girl sketch
oh it's really gonna bake your noodle is
the Karen the girl who Jim eventually
dates in a few seasons is played by
rashida Jones
it was acting job before the office was
you guessed it in sketches on
Chappelle's Show I'm pretty sure this is
just a sin for the space-time continuum
may it rest in pieces that's actually
another salesman here yeah I can redo it
if you want to do that
I'll give you discount I've never worked
in sales but if your company doesn't
have rules forbidding in-house sniping
on long-term contracts find a new
company the fact that anyone works in
this environment for longer than a month
is maybe the biggest sin of the show ah
come on there's no way Jim would be able
to stand up right now ah not a bad day
my hair Jim didn't even have to use his
a cake
good morning oh and in case I don't see
you good afternoon good evening and good
night the guy mr. Brown not using it
right Joe ruin he's butchering it
I'm could you just let me he insulted us
and they abandon us I've abandoned my
child where's my Oprah moment let's do
it
let's get ugly let's get real now you
wanna get nuts come on let's get nuts